given what you uh experienced back in
2009 what lessons that would
would you have taken from that period uh
to apply
to today's international crisis
yeah it's up to the chairman and that's
boris johnson to lead
the others would respond but i think
this summit will go down as a missed
opportunity
a missed opportunity when we needed 11
billion vaccines
we've only got offered a plan for 1
billion
we needed 50 billion dollars allocated
to the vaccination of the world
and only 5 billion dollars and i think
this summit i'm afraid will also go down
as an unforgivable moral failure when
the richest countries are sitting around
the table with the power to do something
about
it now that we've discovered the vaccine
we have not set out the comprehensive
plan
that will deliver vaccination by the
middle of next year
boris johnson said on sunday that this
would be the greatest feat in medical
history he said it was the great
challenge of postwar history
well i'm afraid there will be smiles but
there are not solutions
millions of people will go unvaccinated
and thousands of people i'm afraid will
die
to be fair this is not just
boris johnson of course uh mr biden mr
macron
uh nits and merkel they've all agreed
to this uh this is um if you want to put
it that way
a comprehensive global failure then
isn't it
well mrs merkel and mr trudeau did a
letter to the financial times only two
days ago in which they
said they wanted the g7 to share the
cost 67
of the cost which is about 50 billion
over two years of vaccinating
and protecting the world with testing
and protective equipment
now i'll wait to see the final
communique but it looks as if
there is a huge gap between what boris
johnson promised last sunday
and what is actually being delivered and
i'm afraid it is a
gap in funding and i'm afraid it also
comes back to the british cuts in
overseas aid that we're not prepared
to put up enough money to deal with
problems that the world faces
even when at the benefits in extra
economic activity if the world gets back
to growth and trade
uh far outweigh the costs of doing this
and so boris johnson really has got to
think
are we to leave this problem uh to the
g20
to next year or the year after because
on the basis of the evidence i see
the whole world will not be vaccinated
by the middle of 2022
and we will have a huge problem of a
division between the richest countries
that are safe and the poorest countries
that are not safe
but then the problem will come back to
haunt the richest countries because we
all have contagion
spreading that may hurt even the people
who are vaccinated
because of mutations and variants
is it just a matter of funding though we
heard the foreign secretary saying
earlier
that this is also a question of the
mechanism so
for example do you really trust the
world health organization
to be able to dispense
that level of vaccination the 11 billion
or whatever
number you choose that you think is
ideal
well it's at least 11 billion and it's
not just the who who's saying that
every government that's involved in
what's called kovacs accepts that these
are the figures
you know what we did in britain was the
right way to do when we're facing
the problems of the world what you do is
you put up the money
you pre-order the vaccines you then
build up the manufacturing capacity
and then you have factories in this case
in every continent and unless you have
this virtuous circle which starts
with the guarantee of funding then you
will not solve the problem
and i fear that the g7 has not only
missed this opportunity
but it will take months before the world
gets back to discussing this again
in the most coherent way we need a plan
we don't have yet a plan
we're going to have a shortage of
vaccines over the summer and we're still
not going to meet the 11 billion
that most people who look at this
seriously say is needed
1 billion is welcome but faced with the
need for
11 billion really the g7 the richest
countries should have done much more
in your book um which is called seven
ways to change the world
you said that the pan after the pandemic
is over we'll still have
260 million children not in education
but the problems that we're facing can't
all just be put down to covid can they
even if the disease makes those problems
worse well the sustainable development
goals that britain signed up to every
country signed up to say
everybody in education by the year 2030.
now britain has done a lot in the past
we've offered
to fund the education of 40 million with
the g7 countries
but that's 40 million girls but there
will be 400
million girls leaving school or not at
school
over the next few years leaving school
without qualifications
so again we're dealing with only a
fraction of the problem it's the gap
trevor between
the promises that the international
community makes boris johnson made on
sunday
and the reality that when it comes to it
yes they'll all be smiles at the end of
the summit
but where's the substance when we need
to get the vaccinations in place
we need to get children back to school
we need obviously
also to deal with this escalating
problem of poverty around the world
there are 150 million more people in
poverty
since the start of the crisis and that's
150 million people who don't really have
the food
that they need to survive
a quick question about domestic policy
does it were
the irish prime minister told us this
morning that he thought
a solution to the northern ireland
protocol
issue was possible where what would you
be proposing
were you in the prime minister's seat
today
this can only be solved by people
getting around the table and talking
about it
there are difficulties in administration
but the protocol will not change in my
view over the next few months
you know when i was prime minister even
at the height of the financial crisis i
spent days in northern ireland
talking to all the parties listening to
their complaints their queries
answering some of their problems and
this needs time it needs a prime
minister who is prepared to spend the
time
speaking to people in every part of
northern ireland as well as speaking to
the government of ireland
and the european union and it can't be
done simply by a few statements that
uh the protocol may need to be looked at
again or alternatively that someone else
has got to solve the problem for him
he's got to spend the time and it's only
the prime minister i'm afraid
and it does come back to who's in charge
you can't solve this northern ireland
problem without the prime minister
engaging it
with the fullest attention that will be
needed as the g7 summit finishes
but subtly without any
great fanfare the truth is that
what they say in northern ireland or
some people say in north island
is that this is all undermining northern
ireland's place
in the union do you not fear that drift
to a separate separatism
well i think boris johnson again has got
to understand that this is a union of
england scotland wales and northern
ireland
and each part of that union has got its
own cultural traditions its own
sensitivities
its own needs and its own aspirations
and you've got to work at this
the job of a prime minister and perhaps
he's the only
person that can do it he or she is to
unite the whole country to bring people
together
i i believe there should be a forum that
brings together the nations and the
regions in a more systematic way
so that common problems are discussed
chaired by the prime minister
but you can't assume that the united
kingdom is going to hold together
if you don't work at it and that demands
efforts
cooperation policies for cooperation
instruments for cooperation
and of course a determination that
cooperation is going to work
in your book um if we can return to
the global situation henry kissinger
talks about a new cold war between
liberal democracies and authoritarian
states by which
he means russia and china do you agree
with that analysis and if so
what can we do to avoid it or is it
inevitable i think he's right
i think he's right about the risk and
the risk is even greater than he's
describing it's one world two systems
it's not just a cold war it's people
moving in a completely different
direction
one international monetary fund for the
west one for asia
one world bank for the west one for asia
one currency
uh or set of currencies dominating in
the west one in asia
and i think we've got to avoid that i
have always stood out against the human
rights policies of china
we had a human rights dialogue with
china but i've always also
said that where we can agree like on
climate change like
actually a plan to vaccinate the world
like
on dealing with some of the huge global
problems we face including economic
growth in the poorest countries we have
to find a way to work together i suspect
that's what
joe biden wants to do amidst the the
fiery rhetoric against china
he believes there are areas where you
can cooperate and you should
but also areas where you've got to say
very clearly we disagree entirely with
what you're doing
and we will try to persuade you to
change your mind but you have to
concentrate
in a world as fragile as this where we
have huge problems
that are global we have to concentrate
on finding ways to work together where
we can
okay we have we have a very short time
but i i don't think i can let you go
without asking you a question
about scotland and labor um
no it's not an argument that labor
probably is not where it would like to
be
in polls and elections looking at the
recent
local elections the prospect of losing
battley and so on but a big issue for
the labour party
is its position in scotland which is
dire what should labour be doing
to re restore and regain its status in
scotland
well we've got to show that we're both
the party of social justice
and that the scottish national party are
not delivering that despite all their
promises
and we're the party of solidarity uh in
in
in this interdependent world there is no
future in nations that are neighboring
nations fighting each other
and i fear 50 years of conflict between
scotland and england
if we don't get these problems sorted
out so we have got to be the party
of solidarity of talking about empathy
reciprocity cooperation
and sharing and of course we found
during the vaccination effort
that when we cooperate we get things
done british
pre-purchasing scottish delivery in
scotland of the vaccine
now that's a way forward on health but
it's a way forward on climate change
which
cannot be solved without countries
working together and the recovery
where jobs are going to be needed to be
created and we need
all the resources of the united kingdom
in every part of the united kingdom put
to work